[Music]
so
welcome back everyone happy star wars
day may the fourth be with you this is
going to be my star wars the clone wars
season 7 episode 12
finale video the last episode of the
clone wars
ever if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the star
wars videos i will talk about what's
happening with ahsoka
next during the mandalorian season 2 at
the end of the video
as part of this video because her
timeline continues into present day
but careful for spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll do top
10 wtf and easter eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode victory in death
so this refers to a lot of different
victories and a lot of different deaths
a lot of people died in the days after
the end of the war
the republic's victory in the war
against the separatists they won the
clone wars
but also on the bad side of that the
emperor's victory against the jedi he
was able to turn anakin skywalker and
strike down the jedi
remember the movie is called revenge of
the sith so this sort of overlaps with
the ending of revenge of the sith i'll
talk about that as we work through the
video too
but when you're talking about the deaths
you have the deaths of the clones during
this episode you have the death of the
jedi order
in the metaphorical death of the
relationship between anakin skywalker
and ahsoka
even though ahsoka did not know that
darth vader was anakin skywalker till
later in the timeline
she knows something terrible happened
that anakin did something she sensed
that through the force
but she doesn't know everything yet it's
very seldom that a tv show can stick the
landing
but i feel like they did an amazing job
with this series finale
i feel like this is exactly what i
wanted from this series
they could just package these last four
episodes and air them as a movie by
themselves or you could do the super cut
with revenge of the sith like a four
hour cut of that movie adding in this
footage where it fits in the timeline
you could also take the victory
reference in the title as a reference to
darth maul's victory as he's able to
escape again
we knew he was going to survive because
he doesn't die until way later in the
timeline anyway
the music at the beginning of the
episode sounded familiar it sounded a
lot like padme's funeral march when she
was being buried at the end of revenge
of the sith
i think that was to help place you in
the timeline like when is this taking
place relative to the ending scenes of
revenge of the sith
i think the timeline goes like this as
the ship is crashing it's while mustafar
is happening and darth vader is almost
killed by obi-wan kenobi
then the final ending scene of him
landing on the moon amidst the wreckage
searching for any survivors is happening
maybe like a week or so
after he becomes darth vader so not a
whole lot of time
goes by between the beginning of the
episode and the time jump at the end
when darth vader shows up
but number nine ahsoka and rex versus
the clones the episode itself picks up
in the moments that the last episode
ended as the clones are trying to bust
into the med bay ahsoka still isn't
ready to kill the clones
there's a lot of her compassion that
comes through in the episode even though
rex is like look they're all gonna die
trying to kill you they don't care that
they used to be your friends but ahsoka
stands fast she's like no i'm not gonna
kill them if i don't have to
they wind up dying anyway under tragic
circumstances because of the crash
but she's determined that they won't die
by her hand so they just do everything
they can to stun them as they make their
way to the hangar bay
rex is still a little surprised that she
let darth maul out like wait a minute
what did you do to darth maul
who number eight winds up destroying the
hyperdrive to just keep them from going
back to the republic space so that the
emperor won't be able to recapture him
he wants to do everything he can to
survive and that means staying as far
away from the emperor and darth vader as
possible
he only knows that anakin has become his
master's new apprentice he was able to
sense the same things that ahsoka was
able to sense through the force
it's a great scene and i love their
reaction later wait a minute what are
you saying the hyperdrive it's
completely gone
there's a clever reference to a new hope
when they say they're caught in the
moon's gravitational field is just a
clever reference to the death star when
for just a hot second during a new hope
they think they've been caught in the
gravitational pull of a small moon
which is no moon at all but the death
star itself based on the timeline of the
prequels they started constructing the
death star
around attack of the clone so it's
actually been under construction for a
long time
in secret when revenge of the sith is
happening the number seven ahsoka's plan
to escape without killing all her former
friends
and allies they have another talk before
they enter the shuttle bay too
rex starts crying saying that these are
all my brothers but they're gonna die
trying to kill you you have to do
something about this then we find out
that her actual plan is
to pretend like he's going to turn her
in just to stall them till they can find
a way to make their way to that ship
he even tries to use logic against the
clones but their programming in their
chips is so
deep that they're like no no that's
bullcrap we're going to kill you it
doesn't matter that she left the jedi
order
once a jedi always a jedi then number
six is they're fighting the clones off
darth maul runs past double-crossing
them to steal the ship out from under
them saying that you asked for this
chaos
here it is peace i'm out of here she's
able to stop the ship from leaving
using the force which is a star wars
rise of skywalker scene
but forced to let him go after too many
clones start attacking them again
just explaining how darth maul escaped
and shows up during the solo a star wars
story post-credits scene
that's not the last time we see darth
maul in the timeline the last
time that we saw him was his final
confrontation with an older
obi-wan kenobi on tatooine during star
wars rebels
right before the events of star wars a
new hope we'll see if darth maul shows
up on the live-action obi-wan kenobi
series but if that takes place
on tatooine then i think the first time
that we see darth maul on tatooine is
actually during rebels so it wouldn't
work out so potential darth maul cameo
just depends on where the obi-wan kenobi
series takes place
then as the ship continues to crash into
the atmosphere so can wrecks try to keep
the clones busy
the droids get destroyed r.i.p droids
you did your duty well
they're able to find one ship that isn't
under maintenance it's a btl-b
y-wing it's the precursor of the modern
day or the classic era y-wing ships
the clones almost get them until the
ship fully enters the atmosphere and
just starts ripping
itself apart under the stress the number
five wizard of oz
ahsoka rex is able to get the ship out
of the hangar but it takes him a minute
to fire it up so it's blowing around in
the atmosphere along with ahsoka who's
blowing around
loose in the atmosphere trying to grab
the ship all i could think about with
her blowing around in this tornado of
parts was dorothy in the wizard of oz
caught in the tornado it's also a visual
callback to the siege of mandalore scene
where she jumps out of the ship and then
starts
jumping from ship to ship on her way
down to the ground
and if you remember they actually did a
scene that's just like this during the
black widow movie it was in all the
trailers with natasha being chased
through the air by taskmaster through
the falling wreckage of a building or a
ship of some kind that's being broken
apart
the number four ahsoka makes it into the
cockpit they land on the ground
in the wreckage and bury all the clones
then fakes her death
by leaving one of her lightsabers behind
one of the ones that anakin had just
given her a couple days ago
it's only been a couple days since
anakin last saw her not that much time
has passed
and even though she leaves with the one
lightsaber by the time we get to star
wars rebels
she gets the second one back so
eventually she does have both of her
lightsabers back
but then number three we get our big
anakin skywalker darth vader cameo scene
so there's a short time jump it's
implied that this is taking place maybe
a couple days after
the end of revenge of the sith probably
less than a week not that much time
anakin skywalker who has since become
darth vader comes in a sentinel-class
landing craft from the original trilogy
to search the wreckage for signs of
ahsoka the emperor probably ordered him
to investigate this wreckage but the
real reason he's here is to search for
ahsoka
because darth vader's primary mission in
the years after
revenge of the sith was to hunt down the
rest of the jedi that survived order 66
surprisingly maybe unsurprisingly there
were a lot of jedi that survived the
purge
yoda among them obi-wan kenobi obviously
you have anakin skywalker's children
luke and leia
there are a lot of force-sensitive
people out there so the emperor tells
darth vader go
find them and kill them all he's
accompanied by classic era storm
troopers who are made up of the
surviving clones and new regular human
conscripts
there were still some clones that were
part of the imperial army at first but
they slowly died off you see an imperial
probe droid
buzzing around in the background it's
meant to be a big empire strikes back
hoth reference but in terms of timeline
this is really soon
right after the ending of revenge of the
sith the number two
darth vader finds ahsoka's lightsaber
the music does all the work of conveying
his emotions he has no dialogue you just
hear his darth vader breathing sounds
out of his mask
you have to remember that in the early
days after becoming darth vader and
donning the sith armor
he still had a lot of anakin skywalker
left in him he hadn't buried all of
those emotions yet
it was still pretty fresh how much he
cared about ahsoka and he'd only seen
her just a couple weeks before and given
her these lightsabers
so you can argue in the comments about
what he would have done had he found
ahsoka on this
moon he definitely would have fought her
but he might have fought her to a
standstill and then allowed her to
escape
even later in the timeline after he's
been darth vader for a long time
after he learns of the existence of luke
skywalker his children in leia
he tells luke skywalker that he
basically cannot defy the emperor i must
do
as he asks meaning that he is conflicted
he always is conflicted
all through his history as darth vader
these years before the original trilogy
even during the original trilogy
he is very conflicted about what he's
doing his emotions are
all over the place so you can just feel
the sadness in the air when he ignites
her lightsaber then looks up in the sky
like he's wondering whether or not this
is fake and she survived maybe he's
hoping that she survived
they did have a confrontation later that
i'll talk about in a second too during
star wars rebels
but he deactivates the lightsaber and
you see him walking away in the
reflection of the clone trooper helmet
painted orange to look like ahsoka's
face the music
was fantastic while this was all
happening so number one wtf
what happens next and what's going on
with ahsoka and the mandalorian season
two
so if you want to get into the details
for what happens with darth vader and
ahsoka
right after this moment there is an
ahsoka book that they wrote about her
early years after the events of the
prequels
all of anakin skywalker's early years as
darth vader are covered during the newer
darth vader comic book as he's going
around the galaxy on the orders of the
emperor
it's also important to remember that
when this is all happening right here at
the end of the episode ahsoka still
doesn't know that anakin had taken the
darth vader identity
that doesn't happen until way later in
the timeline and they didn't have their
next direct confrontation
until the events of star wars rebels
twilight of the apprentice
i won't leave you not this time
[Music]
then you will die
even though a lot of people weren't huge
fans of star wars rebels series in
general
that particular event is one of the best
moments from star wars rebels and one of
the best ahsoka
darth vader moments ever the last we saw
ahsoka was
right after the end of return of the
jedi she's around her late 30s early 40s
she's got some more city miles on her
and she and sabine wren were going off
into the unknown regions to look for
ezra bridger so that's the last we saw
her before she shows up in the
mandalorian season two
and the mandalorian series takes place
about five years after return of the
jedi so a couple more years have gone by
and she's supposed to be in her early
40s when she shows up
played live action by rosario dawson
we don't really know what she's going to
look like live action yet they haven't
posted any official pictures
but a lot of this fan art is probably
really close to what she's going to look
like
everyone post all your favorite moments
from the clone wars either from this
episode
or from the series in general i'm not
expecting them to do any more clone wars
episodes but i do think that they will
do another new animated series soon
dave filoni is one of the executive
producers on the mandalorian as well so
he does a lot of mandalorian stuff which
is why ahsoka is probably showing up on
that
they did just start premiering a special
mandalorian
series in addition to the season one
episodes those are all brand new they
just started airing today i believe
they'll be releasing new episodes on
fridays so i'll do my episode one video
for that that should post tomorrow
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see that when i
post it
but everyone click here for the
mandalorian season 2 teaser trailer
video
and click here for my brand new rick and
morty season 4 episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching may the
4th be with you everyone stay safe
i'll see you guys tonight